[MUSIC]
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> 2012 was a life changing year for me.
In May I got pregnant, and then I found
out I was having a high risk pregnancy,
requiring me to be on bed rest for
16 hours a day on my side.
So to kill time and entertain myself,
I decided to go on amazon.com and
buy all the highly rated parenting
books and started reading them.
The more I read,
the more confident I got about my
ability to take on this new challenge.
I knew it was going to be hard,
but in typical Vadita fashion,
I had figured out everything that
could potentially go wrong, and
then come up with mitigation
strategies to address those challenges.
So here I was ready to take this on,
and then came Zara.
A very happy and healthy baby, 4.5 pounds,
17.5 inches long with a vocal
capacity of 88 decibels.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Those first few moments were so
precious, the first few years not so much.
I went back to taking a full time job,
which was very stressful.
My husband Sindeep, was trying to start
a new business, so he also was working
really long hours, we hired a full
time nanny to take care of Zara.
Zara was spending a lot of time with
the nanny, so not surprisingly,
Zara got really attached to the nanny.
And this really bothered me.
But then I remembered in one of the books
that I had read, Sheryl Sandburg in
her book, Lean In, talked about being in
the exact same predicament, that I was in.
So I was like hey, Sheryl went through
this, you're going through this,
it's really no big deal,
just don't sweat it.
But that advice was really hard for
me to hold onto.
The evenings got progressively harder,
and the weekends were even worse.
Much of what I had read in those books was
just not working for me on a daily basis.
And it didn't take me long to figure out
there was somebody else in the house
who had it all figured out.
Sindeep knew exactly what to say,
how to say it,
what to do, when to do it, how to do it.
He essentially had the motherly
instinct that was supposed to be mine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was my precious gift for
carrying our child for nine months.
And for the first time in my life,
I was jealous of Sindeep.
How could it be that I was so successful
at work, getting stellar performance
reviews, and at home,
I couldn't even put Legos together?
It really frustrated me to see that, and
I carried this frustration
into work everyday.
So I distinctly remember that day in June
2015, I was basically running from meeting
to meeting trying to cope with everything
that was being thrown at me that day.
And it was Zara's wellness
appointment at 2:00 PM that day,
and I didn't want to be late.
But despite my best intentions I was late,
so I showed up,
the appointment went really well.
Zara was thriving as a toddler, and
then when the appointment was over
Sindeep took Zara back to the car,
while I waited there, in the office.
In this really tiny space,
probably ten feet by five feet waiting for
my pediatrician to print
her growth charts.
So here I was standing there
very lost in my thoughts and
just staring at the ground.
And she looked at me and
she said, So how's it going?
I had no idea what it was
about those words, but
the next thing I knew, I was crying,
and this was no gentle cry.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This was really loud and
ugly with lots of Kleenex,
smudged eyeliner, I was a mess.
And I didn't know what it was, there was
nothing special about what she said, but
it was as if she knew exactly
what was going on in my mind.
She'd probably seen this before,
but for me, it was a first.
And I was standing there
feeling really lost, and
completely defeated by motherhood.
It took me several days to
process what had occurred,
and I think I finally figured it out.
>From the day I got pregnant and
possibly even before I conceived,
I had this image of this perfect mom.
This mom who is on time for
all her appointments,
her house looks really clean,
the sink is not piled with dirty dishes.
The laundry is completely taken
care of tucked away in drawers,
she organizes play dates for her daughter.
She reads to her daughter probably
in more than two languages.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And she's on top of it, and
I was miles away from achieving any
of this, on a consistent basis.
And this really may have bothered me,
it made me frustrated and
angry, which made me
restless in my own skin.
And my daughter could feel that,
which is why she was running away from me,
making me feel worse and
this cycle just continued.
So I have spent a lot of
time thinking about this and
many Whiteboard sessions later,
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think I finally cracked the code on
this internal dichotomy of a personality
trait that is so ingrained in me.
So one one hand,
this continuous strive for perfection
leads to stress, anxiety,
it lowers my confidence levels.
It makes me unsure of myself, and
in many ways it really increases my
desire to be accepted in this world,
it's what made those first few
years with Zara really hard.
But on the other hand, it's this
strive for perfection that results in
beautiful products, whether that is
at work or at home in the kitchen.
You can ask my husband about
every meal that I cook,
it is done in the absolute hard way,
there are no short cuts.
But I think what it results in is
the perfect meal, or at least perfect for
my status, and it makes me happy.
And I really can not forget it is that
perfection that got me to the GSE.
This dichotomy is really tense.
But this tension is beautiful,
it exists even today.
What does not exist today though,
is this constant agony to try to fight it,
because what I realized is that
at my core, I'm a perfectionist.
I just can not change that,
what I can change is how and
when I apply it to my life.
And because essentially what
I don't do anymore is try
to apply this perfectionism
to relationships.
because relationships are not like
recipes, two tablespoons of love,
and three teaspoons of compassion
does not equal a happy baby.
Letting my guard down to really be myself,
and who I am,
is what makes me the mom I want to be.
And it is this imperfect mom
that Zara loves, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]